[Music]
so um this times 20 which is about 200
books is how many books i read
because
i can speed read so let me show you how
i do that last year alone i read over
200 books and that is while being a
medical student and working full-time
and a huge reason for this is just being
able to read really fast if you
currently identify at all as being an
average speed reader i promise you that
using the three techniques in this video
you'll be able to at least triple your
reading speed in just a few minutes of
practice now i feel that a lot of modern
books or self-help books or business
books literally have more chapters than
legitimate points to make and it becomes
almost a fight for me to be able to save
my time and not waste it on reading a
lot of fluff and useless things now
before i get cancelled i just want to
say this is not a technique that i
recommend or use myself for things like
shakespeare or philosophy or works of
literature or anything nice like that
this is for the sort of authors that
have one good idea and instead of
tweeting it write a whole book on it and
it's therefore very frustrating to go
through all of these things super super
slowly and also i use this in my exam
papers or other places where speed
reading tends to be a huge benefit now
this has been a lifelong journey for me
and i think it's something to do with
the fact that my attention span has more
commitment issues than me so when i was
younger i would have to read faster and
faster and faster to kind of be able to
still not be distracted or stop reading
at all so yeah i just developed this
really fast reading skill and i've
broken it down into three steps for how
to learn to read the first is to train
your eyes the second is to train your
brain and the third is to train your
attention and that's what i'm going to
be breaking down today now let's jump
straight into it with the first part
which is training your eyes and to do
this i would use a physical book
potentially that doesn't have a lot of
images or weird text or things in them
but just has normal text which is
preferably uninterrupted with pictures
inside and the reason for this is
because it's a lot easier to train
depending on how fast you want to learn
or depending on how good you are at the
moment you ideally want to pick a text
which is slightly larger because the
smaller the text the harder this is
going to be so hard mode small text easy
mode bigger text and i quite like the
size of the text in this book um i think
this is perfect to try to practice then
but you might want to go for even
something slightly bigger than this to
start with the first thing you want to
do is to pick a book that you haven't
read please don't pick a book that
you've been reading again and again
because if you have remember what you're
reading it's not going to be fair you're
not actually going to be kind of
stretching your skills a lot and you
might be cheating unintentionally by
just knowing what comes up next so pick
a book which you've wanted to read in a
long time but you've never read before
the first thing you want to do is
establish your baseline there are
between 250 to 500 words in a single
page on a book depending on how big the
spacing is so just have an estimation of
how many words are on a page and then
try to see how long it takes you to read
two or three pages and divide that by
the number of words so you have your
baseline starting rate of reading this
is absolutely not necessary i don't do
these measurements because i don't care
but if you want to see that you have
kind of a huge change or to see where
you can get to it might be fun to
quantify this if you're into that okay
so this is where we're going to start
training our eyes to read faster and
what we're going to be doing here is
something that you can learn in
literally 30 seconds now in this video
and that is to just use your peripheral
vision and what that is is basically if
you've ever had a cranial nerve exam or
in medical school this is what we're
learning to do to patients is you will
ask a patient to look at you straight in
the eye so you can do this on camera now
so if you look at me straight in the eye
can you see my fingers move you probably
can because you're using your peripheral
vision and the same thing for me even
though i'm staring straight at the
camera i can see my fingers move on both
sides and this is what peripheral vision
is so how this helps with speed reading
is that what i would usually do or what
we usually do when we read is we put
that center of our focus so we have the
central vision and then we have our
peripheral vision at the side so what we
usually do is we use our central vision
this like straight direction of our eyes
on the very first word and then we take
it all the way across to the last word
and then we go again and again and again
so the core laser of our focus goes all
the way from left to right from left to
right from left to right and we're not
taking advantage of this peripheral
vision on the side and we can imagine
that we have this huge wasted space here
when our center of the focus is over
here and you can see how that would take
so much longer to go through the whole
text so what we want to do is instead of
skipping our eyes from the start of the
sentence and the line to the end we just
want to skip it throughout the middle so
instead of going from here to here to
here to here what we're doing is
flicking through the center of the text
and using our peripheral vision to read
the sides so this is something you can
legitimately do right now so if you just
pick up a book from anywhere or even as
you're watching this video if you can
just see me and pay a bit more attention
off that side focus you can start to
kind of realize just how much more
you're looking at than you are normally
paying attention to and that's what
you'll be doing with the text so just
draw two lines down the center of the
page or you can try and just like do it
naturally with your eyes but just try to
flick between the middle of the page as
much as possible and just really flick
only in the middle and be able to read
everything from the sides so this is how
you can physically do the speed reading
part but of course we have to also
account for comprehension because you
can see how potentially this is just
scanning the text and not actually
understanding everything so this is what
leads me to my second point which is how
to train your brain to be able to be a
fast reader now this is the biggest
issue that i run in when i'm trying to
teach people in person how to speed read
i've done it to my family and they
always say the same thing oh i didn't
understand anything or i understand
things so much worse i can't do this and
this is where i start to get a bit
frustrated i'm like no no it's normal
it's good it's fine you just have to do
that a lot longer and then you get over
it so basically when we're reading very
slowly it's obviously a lot easier to
comprehend everything that we are
reading but when we are speed reading
there will be a huge amount of
comprehension loss which is basically
reading things but not actually
absorbing what we are kind of seeing so
this is what we need to start getting
used to and what we need to start
challenging if we're always reading at
our 100 comprehension we won't be able
to read faster and faster because the
moment that we start to not understand
things we're just going to stop and go
back to our original speed so i think we
need to use a text that we are not
studying or that's just a practice paper
or a practice book and we just need to
practice reading at 70 or 80
comprehension so
yes i'm literally saying you want to
read something while you're only able to
understand 70 of it and when you're at
that stage then you can start
challenging yourself okay how can i make
myself understand this better and this
is where i'm going to get to my top tip
which is visualization this is so so so
important so no matter what the speed
that you're reading at sometimes even
when i'm reading very very slowly and
i'm just lying in bed i'm sure we've all
had this feeling where we just read a
paragraph it might happen very slowly
and at the end of it someone asks that
asks us what we read and we're just like
i i have i have no clue we just looked
at the text we technically read it but
we didn't understand everything and this
happens at every single speed it's just
so much easier to do at a faster speed
so the key around this is to visualize
what you are reading so you're not
looking at the text you're not scanning
the text you're properly interpreting
this as a mental image in your mind and
you're constantly building this image as
you are reading visualization for
reading is absolutely so so important it
helps me so much with my comprehension
at any speed and it helps me so much
with my learning every time that i'm
reading something i'm drawing a mental
image and of course if i'm doing this in
science it will mean that i have to read
very very slowly to kind of picture the
molecules or what i imagine the
molecules to be but if i'm reading a
literary book or if i'm reading a
business book it's so much easier for me
to visualize these things which allows
me to go to very fast speeds so i would
challenge yourself to learn to visualize
what you are reading about anything can
be visualized like molecules atoms can
be visualized literally anything that we
are reading it's very easy to draw a
mental picture i honestly think this is
why i love reading so much it's kind of
like seeing a movie but even better um
but yeah if you visualize then you'll be
able to comprehend so much more so again
you want to use a book that you haven't
read because you should not be cheating
at the stage but you want to try to
build a picture of whatever is written
in the text and then try to do this as
fast as possible as you are reading and
you will realize that eventually even
though you are maintaining this really
fast speed with peripheral vision you
are able to build this picture in your
head and you might get up to 90 or more
percent comprehension of what you're
actually reading this training your
brain part involves firstly visualizing
everything that you are reading secondly
being comfortable with comprehension
loss but challenging this very harshly
at every single stage and always trying
to train yourself to read at a level
where you are at 70 or 80 comprehension
because that is how you can get faster
and faster at what you are doing and
lastly it's such a good train for your
focus because when you're doing this you
want to be in a very comfortable
position you want to be in a space that
is potentially quite quiet so you can
focus 100 on what you are doing and i
found speed reading to be such a good
way for me to train my focus which is
usually quite scattered but through
training myself to speed read i have
gotten very very good at being able to
laser focus on something when i need to
and you do need this laser focus because
otherwise you're just playing around
with your eyes rather than actually
involving your brain and comprehending
what the hell is happening on paper and
lastly we get to our third point which
is training our focus and maintaining
this exercise without exhaustion and i
will say it is genuinely the most tiring
thing in the world if you are speed
reading really really fast for kind of
like an hour or a prolonged period of
time it genuinely feels like someone
just took out your brain and beat it
with a baseball bat because it is so so
so so so tiring it takes so much energy
and so much focus and it leaves you so
drained in the end that sometimes i
guess it's kind of um like not worth it
almost and it would be worth it to read
a book slower but for example if i'm in
an exam i think it's much more worth it
for me to speed read through my exam
paper because i know it's only going to
be two or three hours and then after
that i can be as tired as i want but
i've been able to do this a lot more
efficiently or sometimes for a book i'm
like oh do i want to waste five hours on
this horrible book or do i want to speed
read it in an hour and then kind of take
the four hours to do something fun but i
have the same amount of information so
these are the kind of calculations that
i'm making when i'm speed reading but
yes it is extremely extremely tiring
which means that the more that we can
adjust our environment to make this more
comfortable for us the better the first
thing i will say is don't try to do this
with books that have really really small
writing um if they're physical books
with really small text that will be so
much more exhausting so i would
recommend actually to use a kindle or an
ipad to read or a computer to read this
as much as possible because on all these
devices you can very easily adjust the
brightness and also adjust the size of
the text so the bigger the text the
easier it is to speed read and to use
our peripheral vision so i would say
ideally if you want to speed read a book
and you know in advance that this is
going to be a bit of a crappy book that
you want to blitz through then i would
prefer to buy that on a kindle rather
than buy the physical book version
because then i know i can speed read it
a lot faster
so that's the first thing adjusting the
screen brightness so either when it's
very dark to have it to a dark screen so
it doesn't tire out my eyes or when it's
daylight to have it to quite a bright
screen so again i can actually see what
i'm reading is really really helpful and
also lastly um this is a bit of a
cheating thing but it really really
helps with speed reading and that is to
spread the attention across many of my
senses so what this means is that
sometimes if i want to speed read a book
i will also buy the audible version of
the book or i will buy the audiobook too
so i will have the physical book in
front of me and i will also be listening
to the audiobook because what that means
is it really really helps me maintain my
focus because for example if i'm speed
reading and i just get tired it's very
easy for me to just do this and leave
but
if i have an audio book it's so much
faff to kind of pause the audio book at
the right spot and then take a tiny
break and then start again so it kind of
forces me to not stop which i mean
sounds a bit toxic but it's all
self-imposed so it's fine um so i will
just play the audiobook while i'm
reading and that will help me speed and
breeze through the book as fast as
possible also things like using your
finger to trace what you are reading
might really help but i think the main
thing here is using a large size text
and that genuinely makes the biggest
difference and also using an audio book
at the same time also really really
helps kind of maintain that focus for
prolonged periods of time and lastly of
course do take breaks because it's
really really tiring it's genuinely
almost like a physical sport and a
competitive activity so it's not just an
easy casual thing that you're doing at
the side it's actually quite hard to do
so breaks are really really important
don't speed read books back to back
because you will literally fry out your
brain um but yeah do it at small periods
at a time i would recommend just trying
this exercise for 15 minutes once or
twice will genuinely really really
increase your reading speed so in that
case if you're actually into this for a
competitive reason then potentially
measuring your speed right now and what
it could become in the future will
really really help see that you've made
a difference but yeah our book fan i
have a video up here that people
absolutely loved on how i make the most
out of the books i read and also here
are a bunch of my self-help
recommendations which potentially all
fall into this category of books to be
spread read otherwise thank you so much
for sending this time with me i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day be
kind to yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think thanks bye